jean marie bigard à vous alors non je
vive le dise le film la scène
l'opération bouchons là on va le faire
une fois pour toutes des prêts
quand on a autant de trucs à vendre
c'est normal c'est normal alors le
bouquin c'est votre premier bouquin oui
ça s'appelle non mais pour qui je me
prends oui chez albin michel
alors c'est un livre pour garder un
livre de les regarder c'est séné de mon
site internet j'avais j'ai un
photomontage chaque jour alors ça
commence par marianne
vous savez je me les met les doigts de
l'homme voyez par exemple quand je vois
ce que je fais il rien que d'urssaf tous
les mois je suis vert jeu sans fin quoi
lui dire tu as pu le lire entièrement à
j'essaie de dire que je les lui du début
avait aussi de 50 kg pour faire le rôle
puis finalement ils ont pris robert de
niro miss world to [ __ ] j'y suis c'est
tout le monde pour rien
et là je suis en colère j'ai envie de me
gratter les couilles mais je peux pas
j'ai mes tâches à mettre la charrue
avant les boeufs bien sûr y est tu sais
je vous disais discrédit un rasta qui a
arrêté de fumer
non mais qu'est ce que c'est que cette
musique de merde jean marie bigard
je me mens et puis alors il ya ça et
puis aussi un disque
oui aussi à dire que vous allez pas de
main morte
tu loges entre juba compétiteur j'ai pas
dans ce but
mais quand j'entends ce genre de
décibels je crois mon élan javier
je balance je trouve le
et je recule
et je remue le regard toujours
oh
deux jours
entre les deux
et quand mort par balle
et attendre
moi je serai là largement paire de bas
non
là
c'est parti pour fair l'été ça va on a
longtemps hésité entre je voulais dire
gré montre là là là là là et on april
alain veut que ces bleus là encore c'est
plus original auquel le livre il ya le
disque puis elle filme aussi qui va
sortir s'appelle la boîte de nuit le 4
juillet en l'histoire c'est une bande de
potes qui sont interdits d'accès dans
l'est dans les discothèques de la région
pendant un an et andré je jouerai à une
boîte de nuit donc dans le garage du
père de l'un d'eux et la boîte s'appelle
la boîte est très vite ça devient
l'endroit très à la mode où tous les
jeunes des alentours vont faire la fête
ce qui ne fait pas les affaires de roger
vous roger moi c'est un gros con qui
tient le macumba
et ça le fait bien chier que les petits
jeunes qui arrivent à monter une boîte
donc je leur créer tout un tas de
d'emmerdements je suis copain avec les
flics faisait montre alors les des
relations crapuleuses et exactement donc
et c'était très très amusant de faire
déjà ce rôle
et puis alors il ya la scène bigard
remet le paquet ya encore des dates
d'ici l'été billard des loyers et qui a
encore des dates tu plaisantes géant bor
90 dates jusqu'à la fin de l'année je
fais que des zénith dé parc expo et
surtout mais c'est vrai danger c'est le
seul qui met dix mille personnes non
merci
et bercy dans la lumière si elle merci
alors bigard bourg vers 6 28 décembre
gardois bercy ça fait un peu vulgaire
vous remercie en même temps bon merci à
les impôts qu'ils ont pas loin c'est
vrai que les roses et donc mais le kiff
c'est de jouer
douze mille personnes en une seule fois
et peut-être de le faire donc il ya
aucun comique qui fait ça non etc mais
ce qui est génial c'est que j'aurai
jamais voulu faire ça j'ai jamais voulu
le faire c'est le spectacle qui le qu'il
le veut on va faire un espèce de théâtre
avec des drapeaux rouges
il ya deux énormes écrans donc tout le
monde sera au septième rang et ça c'est
vraiment magnifique tu peux pas savoir
l'impression que ça fait que tu rentres
tu fais une mimique et que tu as dix
mille personnes qui rigolent en même
temps c'est une drogue dure
je comprends mais j'ai l'impression que
je me suis fait bouffer par le système
hello there ve